[Music]
hey guys so we're here today to talk
about Avary and our content delivery
system so for those of you who don't
know aary is a photo editor SDK and a
suite of apps based on it uh the SDK has
a fully faked and customizable UI and a
number of high quality customizable
Imaging tools uh we are currently on iOS
Android web windows and server and we
have a number of Partners a lot of users
and have had a lot of photos go through
our
system uh so who are we my name is near
I'm the Le service side engineer you see
my likes and dislikes over there and I'm
Jack I'm the director of engineering in
and same with me so some of our tools
have uh content associated with them so
namely effects frames and stickers we uh
sell and distribute content packs so
frame packs effect packs sticker packs
which each include items that you can
use within the tools uh we also provide
messages to users to let them know about
the avilability of new content and I
should mention that when we started this
model we had all of this content bundled
in the binary we were pushing updates to
push new content uh and that quickly led
us to our first story uh which we'll be
coming back to throughout the
presentation uh we're call the fat tiny
situation
so we want to dynamically deliver the
fat timing stickers to our users fat
timing is this adorable cat down here uh
who's himself into some bread and we
don't want to have to update our app to
give this to our users who are actively
using it so that'll hand it to
here so in order to solve the fat
planing situation we created something
called the content delivery system what
we're doing as a
CDs and the initial version that we had
of this allowed us to solve the first
problem that we had in the fat situation
which is we want to be able to deliver
content Al together from our servers uh
the system I'll just gloss over it it's
not really important but the first
version of this important things note
are that we had to sort of pre-compute
everything and put it on uh in static
files it was all hosted on static files
on S3 which is Amazon's blob storage and
so it was a very inflexible system
everything had to sort of be figured out
in advance and uh there was no server
generating these responses when a device
wanted to figure out what content was
available and it would hit a server it
wasn't our server it was Amazon server
and also mention uh because this is a
beat up we're using MySQL at the
time we realized that not really work
for reasons we'll go
into so version one came out uh we
launched it in I think February this
year it worked well it solved the
initial fat tiny problem but then we had
a second fat tiny problem that we wanted
to address so our story was we wanted to
display the same fat tiny sticker pack
but we wanted to Target only users of
the app pick stitch like Jack mentioned
we have an SDK that's edible in people's
app so pix is one of our large Partners
we wanted to be able to Target their
users only those who were in Japan and
only those who used iOS 7 we realized
that for generating revenue for selling
content targeting specific users based
on specific what we call scope
parameters was very important as the
company grew so again I'll mention that
those three bolded terms on the second
line uh users what app they're using
what country they're in what language
they speak or rather set have set their
devices to what operating system they're
on what platform they're on what version
of the SDK they're using all those
things we call scope parameters they're
things that define who the user is who's
making the request to figure out what
content is available so the question was
how could we do this because we couldn't
do it with version one so we came up
with version two
CDs and I'll just quickly uh go over the
stack that we used you'll recognize this
guy MB but the rest of it imagine that
there users out there Jack mentioned
that we have 50 million monthly active
users on different devices and they want
to figure out what content is available
for me to download so they make a call
to our system they initially hit a
Content delivery Network which uh is
just an additional layer of caching that
we have and we use a company called AI
to provide that service it filters
through to a load balancer which
distributes load across servers that we
have this whole system is running on
Amazon's Cloud uh Amazon web services or
Cloud platform the load gets distributed
across servers that are all running
nodejs and nodejs interacting with a
single cluster mango cluster that's our
backend and all of this is managed
through an internal system that we have
we call Paula and we'll get to Paula
later on but uh all of our data is sort
in here at
M so why did we choose mongod DB before
we show you what we actually did with it
uh as I mentioned we we're using no JS
and I don't know if any of you have
familiarity with it it's a technology
that's getting more and more popular but
with the interaction between and
node is incredible it's extremely
seamless uh they're both Json based
which makes writing queries in no to run
against incredibly powerful and
flexible it's schless and uh one of the
things I should mention is that although
SC parameters that we listed before who
the users are based on what platform
they're running on their version of
their operating system or the SDK what
country they're in what app they're
using we don't know that list of
parameters in advance uh the previous
speaker what's your Yeah you mentioned
that you know you don't necessarily know
what you want to filter on in advance
you don't want to have to precompute all
that we have the same exact issue we
didn't want to have to define a schema
that defined that restricted what we
were able to selectively set cont send
content to so being schist in mongodb
was incredibly powerful for that uh this
was a very read heavy system if I go
back to this slide these are 5050
million people out here they're making
requests constantly millions and
millions of times a day to hit a system
that needs to deliver content really
quickly excels at read heavy
operations and uh it was a relatively
small data set because we don't have
that much content out there or that many
different permutations of the content
that we can deliver so uh you know that
made us choose mongodb for another
reason because we didn't need one of
those big data service providers out
there all right so a little bit on how
it works now uh
when when the device makes a request to
our server there's a two-step process to
deliver the content the first thing that
the device receives is a manifest and
that is a file that defines the set of
content that the user on that device
should see as well as the version of
that specific content item that the
device should download to present to
them uh so once that manifest is
retrieved the user uh user siice makes
another request to our server for each
content item that it needs meaning that
it is never downloaded before or that it
is out of date on with respect to its
version and gets a Json response that
tells the device what the metadata for
that content pack is so how to display
it and then delivers as well uh paths to
all assets where it can download things
like stickers and
Frames all right so one more addition to
the fat time situation uh near mentioned
that on the first version of the system
there was a lot of excess data delivered
uh because we didn't know who the
requesting device was what the
requesting device was so this story is
that we want to manage a fat tiny
sticker pack as a single entity but we
want to deliver it to each device in its
own optimal format so how did we do that
so we came up with something called the
response formatting model so on the left
side we have what's called a Content
entry and that's like a sticker pack or
an effect pack or a frame pack and that
is a single Json file that describes
everything there is to describe about
that content item uh so in the middle we
have entities called response formats
and these are Json schemas and they
serve two purposes one is to uh Define
the format and the structure of the
responses that we're going to deliver to
a certain type of device and the other
is to say how to populate that response
with the correct data so so uh starting
from the left the uh there's a process
called deployment by which we generate
responses starting from the left uh the
content entry is uh processed by uh a
piece of code that takes response
formats and uses them to generate actual
responses and each one of these is
adjacent document as I mentioned and is
stored in a collection specific to the
type of thing that it is so we go into a
little bit more detail on that um I've
for a reference left the diagram up in
the upper right corner but the following
slides are really based on this model uh
so content formats we didn't see those
in the diagram but they're very
important so they Define exactly how a
Content entry is structured and again a
Content entry is something like a
sticker pack or an effect pack or a
message frame pack Etc um so it's a Json
schema uh which is a specification for
Jason that's gaining traction I would
say uh and it basically defines the type
of each field and the structure of a
Jason document uh we added a couple of
properties and custom types to handle
things like uh images that we needed to
upload or fields that weren't standard
uh to Json schema and the purpose of
this is to Define how a Content entry is
structured and also to validate its
entries before is actually inserted into
mongod DV and I should mention that we
did a little bit of work to extend the
functionality to accommodate things like
the custom types and the ended
properties uh so now the response
formats so there is the entry which is
validated by the uh content format the
response format is that middle Hollow
shape up there it is also ajacent schema
as I mentioned before and its purpose is
to define the structure of the response
and to Define how a response is actually
generated based on a Content entry
so there's a special property that we
added called data key and that defines
which field in the Json of the content
entry should be uh looked up to populate
a given field in the
response um so I'll go into even more
detail on that now so I mentioned that
the process by which we generate
responses is called content deployment
so uh there's from our management system
someone creates an entry uh so they post
to an endpoint it's validated against
the content format as I mentioned and
then it's ready for insertion so we
insert it into the
collection that holds content entries uh
when that succeeds we have a second step
which is find all relevant response
formats so a relevant response format uh
let's say that the CMS entry the content
entry uh is an effect pack we would find
all uh response formats that are for
effect packs and they they're specific
to different types of devices I should
mention so uh a response format
represent the response that a standard
resolution iPhone 4 expects or an iPad
Air expects or an Android device expense
with a specific resolution in form
factor uh so we find all those response
formats and we deploy so the process of
deploying uh is as follows uh in the
response format for a given field we
look at the data key uh so for ID the
data key is identified uh we look up
that identifier in the CM the content
entry CMS entry and find its value so in
this case that's com. stickers. 234 F
and we populate the field in the
response with that value so on the right
you see ID now has a value comp.
stickers we do the same thing for
metadata there's a a hierarchy in the
organization but it doesn't matter uh we
just use the dot to separate that
hierarchy so we look up the metadata
display name value which is hats and we
populate the name field with that uh
same goes for images they're really just
do objects that have paths uh for
different sizes that we have uh that we
need to deliver so the I image path is
populated with that field and if we
encounter an array that we want to map
it's the same process we just look up
the array get its value and insert it
and there's one more thing here of note
for each response that we generate we
append a field called version key and
that uniquely identifies that response
uh so if I go into the next slide I
mentioned that manifests describe the
set of content in their versions that
are delivered to the device uh so this
is what a manifest looks like lovely uh
there's a stickers array and that says
this device should be able to see these
two stickers the the one with identify.
stickers2 and the one below it uh and
the version of that content it should
have is represented by this version key
so that tells the device to get this
version um same for frames there's a
single frame that this uh specific
manifest says that the device should
have access to and that's the frame pack
with identifier
that's displayed there so this is sort
of an interesting problem for us we need
to be able to figure out what the most
recent and applicable version key is for
a given content pack in fact for every
content pack in the Manifest so manifest
deployment uh is very similar to content
deployment but there's an extra step uh
and we need to as I said efficiently
find the most recent version keys for
every content pack sorry every content
entry of the right format so to do that
we use Mongo's aggregation framework and
we have a three-step query that we do
the first step is to match uh all
documents so all responses that were
formatted with the correct format ID and
that are in the set of identifiers that
the uh manifest contains so once we have
that set of documents we sort them in
Reverse chronolog chronological order so
we have the most recent ones and then we
group them by identifier and select just
the first version key meaning the most
recent version key for that identifier
and with that we have a mapping of
identifier to the most applicable and
most recent version of the content and
we're able to populate a manifest with
the correct version Keys using that
quer so I'll end it over to
near so that is some heavy stuff that
Jack just went into uh and some people
look confused out there so I just want
to bring us back to a higher level again
and explain why we want to do this just
so everybody's on the same page so if I
take us back to this
slide this column here these shapes are
the responses that we want to actually
deliver to the devices right we said we
want iOS retina specific devices that
are able to consume us data and expect
to see it in a certain way we want them
to get the triangle because that's how
they expect to consume data and and the
squares go to let's say Android devices
that expect a different format for the
data but they're all derived from the
same thing they're all seeing the same
sticker pack so internally we only want
to put one Circle in there we only want
to put one fat tiny sticker pack in our
system and we want to have an automated
system that figures out what the devic
need does that make sense question how
often do people expect to get to so the
we'll go into that a little bit but
every time that uh a person basically
launches an app with our SDK a call is
made to the Manifest endpoint which is
you know after we deploy all this
content we put together a list of what
content the specific device should
download this is retrieved on every app
launch and if there's anything in here
that the device does not yet have or
that they don't have the most recent
version of they'll make additional calls
to retrieve that content does that
answer your question yeah
cool all right so now that we've gotten
this far we have a bunch of manifests
those manifests all
uh list what content is available and to
bring us back to the second fat tiny
situation the question that we had was
how do we target this to only Japanese
users in Japan let's say who are using
pix Stitch right or oron iOS so every
manifest has a scope which is a
combination of all those different scope
parameters any possible parameter that
we could want to Target on we can put
them in a scope in every manifest
that's deployed has a scope associated
with it and that scope says these are
the users that should see let's just
walk through these examples here
manifest one here we're targeting people
who are using ABC let's say that
corresponds to pix Stitch so only pix
Stitch user users should see the content
that I'm not showing here but that's
part of this Jason document in uh
and only those users that are in Japan
now notice that this is an array that
could be in Japan or in China or in
Ireland right it could be any
combination of things and using
makes that really flexible and then we
have a formatting scope not only weet
targeting these users this is only
consumable by users who are using iOS we
only want iOS users to use this so they
should get a format that is relevant to
iOS and to a format that is uh
consumable by at least iOS version
7.0 and on the right side we have users
that are sending requests constantly to
try and get their manifest and they list
off all of these scope rers this user is
hitting our server and he's saying I'm
using pix
I'm in Japan my language is Japanese my
platform is IOS and I have OS version
7.2 so he's sending this request we have
a bunch of manifest in our database the
question is how do we send him the right
response so this is where more so
on the left side you have that user
sending us request we've color coded the
different scope parameters they sent us
I'll mention that the OS version which
is stored OS version and SDK version are
stored in do notation for versions but
we can't do range comparisons for that
so we convert those into integers in
or sorry they're stored in
that way they're converted when we do
this clearing uh into integer so that we
range comparisons and so we generate a
cleery dynamically this is all generated
when the request comes in we take all
the parameters that they sent us and we
plug it into this query and I'm just
walking through this query there's some
nuances here that we're leaving out
we're happy to go into it later on if
you guys want to talk about it uh but
this query basically says look at the
Manifest collection
and find a manifest that is relevant is
targeting API key Either ABC or n
meaning we've either specified that we
want that target targeted specifically
to pick users or we haven't specified at
all who we want to Target it to meaning
it's more General than that same thing
for Country a manifest that is targeting
either specifically Japanese users or is
not specifying what the country is at
all same thing for language platform and
for menos version because it's a number
and this all we want to do is make sure
that that user has a format that is
consumable
for at least up to his SDK version and
not more or his OS version and not more
than that not sure if I said that
correctly but uh we're saying find a
manifest where the minimum OS version
for consuming that manifest is less than
this particular user uh operating
system and then after we generate that
fine part of it we also want to sort
this right we might get a a bunch of
different manifests that are targeting
different users we might have a manifest
out there that is targeted for Japanese
users and another one that's targeted
for pixit users how do we decide which
one to pay because we only need one so
we have this sort here we basically have
a
predetermined uh hierarchy for which
scope parameters are most important to
us if we match on API key that is the
absolute most important thing and so if
we match on API key that's what we're
going to send back even if we have other
conflicting manifest and we sort on all
these different things and if we match
for all of these different scope
parameters that means we've deployed
multiple versions of the same exact
targeted man so the way that we
differentiate between those is ID minus
one which says just give you the most
recent one limit one meaning only get
one of them right so at the end of this
query we get a manifest that matches on
the most narrowly tailored manifest that
matches on all these different scope
parameters we only get the most recent
one and if there are any conflicts the
system resolves it
automatically does that make sense
if you have any questions again feel
free to ask
us uh all right so the Manifest is
delivered to the user the user now has a
list of all this content and to go back
to the question that was asked uh that
that's delivered once per every time
they launch right but like I said if
their content is either out of date or
if they don't have a particular piece of
content they need to get the most
upto-date version so what they'll do is
they'll just take that version key which
Jack said uniquely identifies all of our
content all they need to do is just say
give me the content with the version key
that's equal to this and because each of
those version Keys represents a
specifically formatted content response
we know exactly what to get so the mango
query for this is way simpler just find
one piece of content that matches that
version key and we just send back that
response so uh you might be saying well
this is quite cumbersome and if we add a
lot more of these the query just gets
more and more complicated and uh as We
Know quering across all these different
things especially when we don't know
what they're going to be in advance
makes it pretty much impossible to Index
this properly so we don't want to have
to do this really complicated query
every time uh these requests we have
millions of users out there a lot of
them are sending us the exact same
combination of skill parameters so if
they've sent us a request before we cat
the response we've done the heavy
lifting we just cat the response that
we've sent it before so we store thato
as well we have a collection called Cash
manifest and another one called Cash
content and when a request comes in like
detour is taken before that query is
generated it first checks in the cach
Manifest collection to see whether or
not we've ever addressed that response
before and done this whole complicated
query and if it matches anything we have
the response in this collection we just
send back that response we don't need to
do this whole complicated thing if not
the detour is taken back to the
complicated query and after that
response is sent back they synchronously
will add that to the cash so that we
don't have
to
all right so uh the system that manages
this internally as we mentioned we call
it Paula a lot of people ask us why we
call it Paula you will find out the
answer to that question if you come
interview at adary we are hiring and uh
and that's our way to incentivize you to
come we don't have T-shirts we
don't
so as I mentioned content formats Define
uh the structure of how a Content entry
is so uh meaning they say exactly what
the Json for say an effect pack should
look like so one of the advantages of
that is that we can validate the entries
before we insert them into to make
sure that they're no problems another
cool side effect of that is that we can
autogenerate our collection UI for all
of these content types in a way that
means we never have to change our
frontend code uh when we make uh we add
a fields to an effect fact for instance
so this is the actual page where we
create an effect pack and each each
field that you see here each text field
is a uh Json has a Json uh schema sub
schema for the field that is a string
this one has a special property that
says it's a long string so xb's big uh
the check box as you see are Boolean uh
there's number support and as you can
see there's image support as well and
that's another reason we added the
Custom Image type to uh to the Jon schem
of
functionality so just uh two more cool
use cases that we found for and
building system so Paula that system you
were just looking at that's our internal
management system but we don't
necessarily want every person in our
organization to access every different
part there are parts that are only
accessible to admins to turn permissions
on and off there are parts that are only
accessible to devs right we don't want
designers coming in and changing around
our schemas for our database uh so we
have a collection a user collection for
who has access to Paula and we can use
Mongo's cool uh push and pop onto arrays
to manage the permission so every time a
request comes into Paula every time
anybody clicks on anything basically and
an HTTP request is made we check whether
the user who's logged in there's
authentication is the user who's logged
in does he have permission to access
this particular part so our routing
mechanism in node uh has permissions
that are associated with every endpoint
and those are enforced through mango and
the second thing um we we'll go into the
numbers a little bit later but we scale
this out to an enormous number of users
very very quickly and we want it to be
very confident so integration tests were
a critical part of Designing this and uh
doing that in if any of you have
had the ability to do that it's actually
a lot easier and a lot more
straightforward than having to build a
schema designing uh query into some if
you're using my SQL for example to put
that into your integration test where
you'll have to drop and recreate your
databases and your tables all the time
this guy not he knows what we're talking
about so writing integration tests which
you want to happen really fast every
time you make a code change you want to
get it through an integration test as
quickly as possible doing that in
where you don't have to recreate your
entire database every time is very very
easy all right so uh We've rone through
the system and here are the takeways so
we built this over the course of uh 3
months and deployed it and pretty much
within 3 weeks was rolled out to uh 20
million the active users so uh that was
pretty quick but it it worked and it
scaled very gracefully and we see very
little load on our system uh basically
due to the architectural decisions that
we made and I guess also the CDN to be
fair but uh it's working very well so we
had very few struggles with and we
were very happy with it for our specific
use case but that said we did uh sort of
omit a lot of workarounds for little
things uh that didn't support that
we wanted to do some of the queries that
near showed are in reality a little bit
more complicated uh but in general very
happy uh very seamless management and we
have two very happy server side
Engineers and'll have to maintain it
very
much sorry one
more so uh the future that was the
present the future one thing that's sist
on here is we plan on expanding this to
the rest of our Network as well right we
mentioned that we're off 20 million
users we have a lot more monthly active
users in that and this system is growing
we're putting more and more Partners on
the system every day uh we want to be
able to support one thing that we're
working on now is being able to support
translations so we mentioned specific
devices should be getting stuff that's
formatted and consumable by that
particular device but people also speak
different languages and content has text
associated with it titles and the
descriptions and stuff like that and the
names of different effects and and
stickers so we wanted to be able to have
this system also uh when it determines
which particular piece of content or
manifest to send to also figure out what
translation is it appropriate to if the
user sends this language we should know
this guy speaks French he's expecting
this content we see in French so we're
building that into the system now gr
user targeting so uh all these different
scope parameters are sent but we also
have a totally separate part of our
infrastructure which is an analytic
system and we constantly gather
information about what different people
are doing in our app uh maybe use app
boy for parts of that but we gather all
this different information and we if we
were to look at that data and aggregate
that data and be intelligent about it we
would know that users who tend to have
these different combinations of scope
parameters or who do this particular
thing in the app repeatedly they're more
likely to buy this particular type of
content so we want to Target that
content to them right now the system
doesn't support that but eventually if
we combine our analytic system and this
content delivery system we could
hopefully automatically realize like
here's a cluster of people that are more
likely to buy this content CDs yes send
it to and the last thing Paula we
mentioned that we're using that
internally but we have a permission
system and an authentication system and
we have a lot of Partners out there that
use us so one day the dream is to open
it up so that all our partners can use
it uh they can log in and manage their
own content and deploy their own
manifest and that shouldn't be too hard
to do because it was built for that
purpose and that's it if you have any
questions feel free to ask us and I'll
mention again that we are hiring so come
talk to us if
you're
than